l'expérience immersive car niaréla
c'est une oeuvre coup de poing à chaque
destinée à nous faire réfléchir
on se retrouve grâce à la réalité
virtuelle au coeur d'un groupe de
migrants qui tentent de rejoindre les
états unis
myriam achard revue l'oeuvre signée
innaritu à cannes il ya cinq ans et
s'est alors donné la mission de la faire
un jour venir à montréal
j'ai revécu l'expérience hier femme a
autant ému c'est une oeuvre qui restent
avec moi très longtemps et c'est là que
tu vois par exemple c'est la première
fois où j'ai pleuré avec un casque de
réalité virtuelle sur la tête car les
arénas virtuellement présent
physiquement et visible est une
installation multi sensorielle signori
tout le célèbre réalisateur mexicain à
qui on doit entre autres les films
amours chiennes 21 grammes et babel dans
car l'ia rena pa d'acteur mais bien de
vrais migrants et cette immersion
bouleversante ovalie innaritu un oscar
dans le site web chinois se déroule au
début de l'expérience tu les regardes
mais il ya un moment où tu n'es plus
spectateur mais tu es toi-même migrants
et c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
pour moi ça a été tellement puissant
comme tout ce que j'ai vécu la première
fois je le dis encore aujourd'hui j'en
ai des frissons
ouah je ressors à l'instant de la
présentation malheureusement les caméras
sont pas autorisés mais je peux vous
dire que c'est complètement touchant
poignant ça ressemble à rien de ce que
j'ai vu auparavant
on est au courant bien sûr des réalités
des migrants de voir comme ça de façon
aussi incarné c'est plus des
statistiques on est sur place on est
avec eux c'est une expérience
bouleversante qui je sens vont faire
réfléchir de me vanter pour pour
plusieurs semaines encore je vous
conseille s'est présentée ici arsenal
centre d'art contemporain ça s'appelle
carnet y arena par innaritu ici n'est
bien alexandre chartier radio canada
montréal